Democratic activist over on CNN Jake
Tapper had cringe Jean-Pierre on the
show yesterday to talk about Biden's age
and unpopularity press Paul finds that
most Americans believe that President
Biden is too old to be president the
poll looked at 80 year old President
Biden versus 77 year old Donald Trump 77
percent of adults say Biden is too old
to be president 51 percent of adults say
Trump is too old and if you look at the
breakdown by Party Republicans generally
don't think of Trump's age as an issue
but both Democrats and Republicans agree
Biden is too old so here's the question
is the White House worried that
questions about President Biden's
stamina could ultimately impact whether
or not voters will be able to support
him for a second term so I'm going to be
careful about 2024 I can't speak to that
directly but you can talk about the
perception of the public with the
president's family and his age I I'm I'm
happy to talk about that I get asked
that question a lot here's the thing you
know what this president brings to this
Administration is wisdom and experience
and you and that is just true with as
Senator as vice president and now as
president and we just talked about we
had a really and I appreciate the
conversation that we had on Medicare the
the 10 the first 10 tranche of uh of uh
prescription drugs that we just
introduced because of the inflation
reduction act and that is the thing that
the president is able to do is deliver
really move forward historic pieces of
legislation change the lives of
Americans for generations to come and
that is what we focus on the president's
worker and what he's been able to do
look
people have come after the president
about his age they did it in 2019 they
did it in 2020 leading into the general
election and they they did it in 2022.
and guess what he beats them every time
because he has his finger on the pulse
of what it is that the American people
need he talks about issues that really
matter to the American people and he is
delivering is there more work to be done
there's always more work to be done but
we are happy to take that on certainly
not going to talk about 2024 but I what
I can't speak to is what the president
has been able to deliver day after day
for the American people okay so you're
part of the 23 percent of adults who is
not who are not concerned about the
president's ability to be president
because of his age and stamina I got it
that's because we've got to do this one
but 77 but 77 percent of adults are
worried that includes Democrats who are
presumably will vote for him what did
you make of it the other day when uh
former Ambassador and Governor Nikki
Haley uh said that
President Biden is is I'm paraphrasing
here but something along the lines of
you know
um degrading before our eyes and that
ultimately vice president Kamala Harris
will be president in a second term look
again I'm not going to respond directly
to uh to Nikki Haley uh not going to do
that can't do that Hatch Act got to be
really Mindful and careful here what I
can speak to is look at his record look
what he has been able to do we literally
just talked about these 10 drugs and
Medicare being able to negotiate with
pharmaceutical companies which is
something that no other no other
politician has been able to do 33 years
that they've been trying to do it this
President made it made it get it made it
happen this is a president again and you
asked me about Ukraine right you asked
me about the supplemental funding he did
he has done something internationally
right around the world which is bring
our allies and our partners together
especially what we saw after the last
Administration this is a president that
knows how to get the work done who is
focused on the American people that's
what I will speak to you'll speak to his
record and his record stands alone and
it is something that Americans should be
proud of something that we all are proud
of on all of the historic amount of let
pieces of legislation but I'm talking
about his agent is stamina and his
ability to do the job and you're talking
about the record and I understand why
you'd rather talk about the record but
I'm talking about what Americans see
when they turn on the TV and they see
you know Joe Biden's been in politics
since before literally since before you
were born and like that he's he's well
it's aged well let's talk about as we
all do let's talk about this and you all
talked about this back when we were uh
when we were when we were marking the
one-year anniversary right the uh of of
the war in Ukraine the unprovoked war by
Russia what did the president do he went
to Kiev and he was there with the with
the alarms blaring in the back and
people were so impressed that he was
able to be there and look strong and
represent uh represent the Amer the
American people in Kiev uh in a war zone
country and that's what you saw I'm not
saying he's not able to walk no but no
but you're saying of course she's just
giving you talking points right she's
nothing she's just like you could unzip
her and inside you would just see
nothing because she is just in service
to the machine everyone look it's not
specifically about the age okay it's
about the cognitive situation that
clearly has declined